do you think if the roles were reversed
yeah you would have like taken that okay
and you know what it's interesting
you're saying that I called myself out
on it today because my friend said to me
that a guy she was with
made a comment about her weight in the
bedroom and it made me reflect and think
God I've done that to a guy and I
thought who the hell am I
to say that I felt bad
but then he asked me why and I don't lie
you know I'm gonna be honest with you if
we're in a relationship
and um how did he respond yeah it was
hard for him but then he actually got
well like he started training in the gym
he started eating properly we cooked
together like that's why I think that I
came into his life to help him with that
it's really interesting like the it's
like it seems like men can accept
criticism a lot better than women